today's topic all the way from the uk
somebody sent us this
blue therapy video so basically couples
go and see a therapist and the timing is
videotaped
and it's couples therapy and these
people are definitely not paid actors
myself and my boyfriend have been going
through a lot lately
um this is the last leg for us we're
really really hanging in
in our relationship i've seen
opportunity for a social experiment and
i think that
it's best we both come here and get some
help i've been with my partner
for three years now just like everyone
else we've had our ups and downs
you know things happen but coming to
therapy
with a camera for some social experiment
that's just
it's a red flag to be fair and now like
she knows my perspective on this i
prefer we go to a church
and we sit down with a pastor in the
corner listen
i'm gonna say this anybody who actually
wants to successfully
save their marriage or their
relationship does not go on national
television to air out their dirty
laundry
okay there's a reason why there's
patient confidentiality
between shrinks and their patients
a lot of that is very sensitive
information if it got out can bears
people
affect their mental health and it's just
not good that's one
two other paid actors just look at this
as entertainment all right they're good
are they paid actors
i went on their social medias and the
way that they're promoting these
episodes
they're paid actors especially paul like
he was super reluctant to go on this
show didn't like the idea all of a
sudden he's all on like twitter like
oh my gosh check out the next episode
what really i could
yeah i didn't check that at the end of
the day it's tv if you don't know that
reality tv is fake
i got a bridge to sell you brother my
name's denise and i'm your therapist
today
um what would you like to start off with
um
okay i wanna i love you you do know that
right
and i said what she said so
uh what did she want to start off with
um
and then the way he positioned himself
cuz he went
yeah [ __ ] why are we here
i mean look at look at even this frame
where we pause look at how he's staring
at her
my man i don't care if he's acting or
not this man's face is hilarious
he walks into the therapist's office
with a look yo whose mans is this
yo why is this in her own office paul
for example has a lot of
friends he has affluent friends he feels
like he has to fit in
which he he might fit in as friendship
but
when it comes to finances he doesn't
necessarily fit in so if we're looking
at percentage-wise and when they go out
and what they spend
they can afford it we can't but paul
will do it anyway
and then he'll spend the next week or
two chasing the bag he's blown
um which now leaves me in a deficit of
love so there's neglect going on in our
household
did you mix lack of money
for the deficit of love no no
i think because he's chasing the back
and he has to work so much
he can't show as much attention to
herself ah
thank you very much for that my my point
in all this is comes back to the
beginning
you just came out on the internet and
called him a poser yes you aired out his
financial situation
what is you doing he could be as bad as
you want and i'm
you could be telling the truth why would
you tell this
to the whole world basically
emasculating him in a way
if you don't want to save your
relationship this is perfect this is
fantastic
yeah all right so we literally just got
here like we haven't been here for five
minutes
trauma's talking about finance to the
bloody denise someone that we don't even
know
now first of all there is no man that's
out there
with multiple accounts crypto accounts
high interest accounts that's gonna sit
down and show his girl his balance so
she doesn't even know the financial
situation
first so hang on let me just let paul um
speak
regarding the image and the going out
and
you know chasing the bag as showman just
said
you know what's interesting
uh
actually say um being a
city girl what i mean like she's not
from that
would you say that shama is for the
streets
this reminds me of all those the
suburban dads who used to be on vine be
like
hit the fans now watch me whip
watch me no no
look cindy i'm on a horse uh is that
horse gonna
i don't know nene i i actually think
she's right
but let me break it down for you i'm
happy and i'm humble enough
to be the brokeest man in a room full of
millionaires
do you know why okay do you know who
would have the most to benefit in that
type of situation you would
so that's practically how i've been able
to
exponentially grow my income basically
he's taking the whole fake it till you
make it to another extent because at the
end of the day i'm not naive to know
that you are treated how you're
perceived
however be yourself um with the whole
spending above your means should i say
yes we can afford it i'm not saying
we can't because he's the first person
to speak about finances and we need to
save and we need to do this and we need
to do that
but as much as yeah i purchase nice
things paul does a lot of the spending
and in the past
we've had situations where he's invested
and there's been no returns
so i don't feel like i need to suffer at
the expense of his investing
and putting himself in positions to get
deals when not all the time it works out
and i
we are we're together do you know what i
mean we're in a relationship
we're not business partners so i'm
suffering
for nothing do you feel that it's an
equal situation
she just said she's suffering for
nothing okay
so am i nothing that's not what i said
that's why i disagree with him that's
like
listen to what she says basically her
complaint is
bruv you're spending and you're
living above your means
and she don't like that and after that
you're doing all that but there's no
return to that you have to listen to
that if you're spending all that cash
and all that money that hard-earned
money and you know you're not spending
on her
or you're not you know you're not
spending on
y'all i'm not gonna say on her but i'm
saying on y'all
and then she don't see it there's not a
benefit to that let's say for example
you would spend all that money and then
after that
someone would be like hey you know what
you're a cool dude one of the guys that
you're spending with
he's like you know your cool dude let me
give you this like a trip for you
and your girl to go somewhere she would
see
the benefit of you spending all that at
the end of the day she doesn't see the
return of that that that's basically her
complaint
him going into the okay so i'm nothing
that's not even what she said you're not
even trying to hear what you said
you know i mean it's like your
comprehension this is why we're here
because
anytime i bring up at home he dismisses
it okay
you're not comprehending what i'm saying
i've lost literally just explained
it yeah yeah okay look out of everything
i said
you got that bit like paul's
he takes what he wants to take he hears
what he wants to hear and he sees what
he wants to see i'm not dismissing it
right now right we're having a
conversation
you know i don't know you from anywhere
but you're here let's have the
conversation right
so this
[Music]
this dude
this dude's gonna talk about i'm not
dismissing you but you know whatever
you're here
so yeah which then goes into dismissing
her
yo he's amazing what do we do together
aside from work that that is meaningful
is that what you said let me tell you
what we do right
every uh 28 days we have a couple's
review right
oh so how the couple's review works is
we basically you know go over
our individual and collective plans
goals targets and we kind of you know
check
make like a check box type of situation
and we mark stuff off
um help each other out with whatever it
is that we need help with and it's
it's worked basically in our
relationship it hasn't worked so uh
in this checkup are you both as they say
on the same page
we're on the same page as we've been
we're always on the same page because
all paul cares about is if our finances
have grown if our savings has grown
but when i'm confused i thought they
were in a deficit confusion
if he's concerned about the if he's
spending too much
how is he able to be yeah she's certain
about she made it sound like it was
financial straights
but anyways okay her problem seems to
not be about finances it seems to be
more about the emotional neglect so
we'll just
yeah but that's the first hold on that's
the first thing she brought up
okay look i'ma just keep listening i
don't know
paul before you got involved with shoma
how did you run your household
well obviously everything was
self-sustainable self-managed
however at the end of the day i think
the question that you should be asking
chuma is if she is getting into a
relationship with a person like myself
i don't want to say bring it to the
table but what am i bringing to the
table i'm not saying that you don't
bring anything to the table what i'm
saying you need to let her know that
there's certain things that are expected
when when she's receiving you know a
certain
of certain frequencies first of all i
contribute to the bills
um i'm doing my own i take care of
myself of course he buys me things but
i'm
going out to shop for myself i'm also
taking care of the home and him yeah he
might do
most of the finance but i'm bringing a
lot to your life and without me
you will be in deficit you'll be lacking
some things okay all right this is
painting a full picture
this man makes a lot of money he pays
all the bills he wanted a housewife
she does not want to be a full housewife
he wants to go to a church for
counseling she wants to go to therapy
for couples counseling
um they seem to be on different pages
these are things you want to discuss
beforehand
if you're going to get a relationship
with somebody and you make you know
whatever amount of money and you want a
housewife you have to talk to your
partner about that
because if she's a career woman she
might want to stay
a career woman choma probably wouldn't
have as many issues with doing a lot of
the emotional labor at home and doing
all this stuff
considering he's taking care of the
bills if she wasn't also working but
because she's working
and doing this stuff then there feels
like some kind of imbalance but at the
same time
if he takes care of vast majority of the
bills you have to ask yourself
why are you doing that nine to five you
can't expect him to do all that extra
work pay most of those bills
and and do some of the labor at home
that's not the way it works for most
people
does that make sense what i'm saying
though yeah you're not gonna turn
someone into something they're not but
people do that though people get in
relationships hoping their partners are
gonna change
and they don't have important
conversations about the things that
matter to them
wanting a housewife whether or not you
want kids what kind of education what
kind of city you want to live in these
are things you should discuss with each
other
once you guys are starting to get
serious they should be
casual conversations that you have to be
like all right what does this person
stand
is this a complete juxtaposition with my
values if it's too important am i
willing to compromise
and if you can't say yes to willing to
compromise you should seriously start to
consider
whether or not you want to be in that
relationship because last thing you want
to do
is intertwine your lives get seven or
eight years in and then realize
on the important stuff like faith on the
important stuff
like where you guys want to live if you
guys aren't willing to compromise and
there's an imbalance there that could
that could devastate a marriage so have
good dialogue i guess
yeah i get that it's just yeah people
don't talk about that
no people really just think in their
mindset that
people are gonna change ah yeah it's
just gonna give me money
they they they go over the signs they go
over
what's been told and how the person was
in the same
how the person was in the first and they
claimed that the person changed
most of the time but it didn't change
they just didn't change for what you
wanted to be
or for what you wanted to have they
didn't change for what you wanted to
have and then you claim
you don't keep the same energy yeah i do
that's the thing
both of them are not what they
eventually
wanted from each other he wanted to have
a housewife
she wanted to have a man man aside her
all the time
and then they got into the relationship
and expected that they both would change
to something else and then they claim
you know i'm not going to be the same
you're not you don't have the same
energy no they it's not that
they have the same energy it's just that
you went over that let's not get
confused i work
okay paul does not finance me completely
does that make sense yes you earn
significantly more than i do but he
doesn't finance me
all right so if you're talking about me
becoming a housewife clearly
because you're talking about finances
and me bringing something to the table
what's wrong with being a housewife
was that the plan we had when we first
met it's a genuine question
i don't want to be a housewife there's
nothing wrong with it but i don't want
to be a housewife i have a choice
does that make sense if i wanted to be a
housewife i would have become a
housewife that's what
you keep pushing for me to do that's not
what i want to do babe okay
okay he used to clean his own house and
change his sheets and cook for himself
we just moved them together six months
ago and all of a sudden that has now
become
my duty and mind alone bearing in mind
both of us
are busy now with myself i'm an earner
you understand i'll go out and i will
come back and i'm bringing the bacon for
real do you understand
if that's the case and i'm able to
provide for the both of us
and kids in the future from now why
would she stress herself
being out trying to earn the same thing
that i already have
sit down let's figure out something i
want to come home with a check
and say babe how should we invest this
and did you notice that things had
changed once shoma moved in
in terms of how i behaved lazy
no no no it just comes down to there's a
misunderstanding
you can't want a baller and then also
expect him to come home and do the
dishes
that's not the way it works when you are
starting to work high figures in those
areas
that's why a lot of them get mains
that's why a lot of them pay for those
things
he wants a housewife and you want a high
earner you have to understand
the odds of you getting a higher earner
who wants to split the home labor
that's ridiculous if you're working both
of them are at fault
yeah it's to me there's like you guys
are looking at each other with contempt
not realizing
your inability to communicate and your
inability to be pragmatic in this
situation is what's causing you guys
problems
either he needs to work less and y'all
split it which he's not going to want to
do
or you need to quit your job and accept
their old housewife or option three
you guys split but this conversation is
stupid
when we first started dating um she was
happy with you know the drive the
ambition
you know me taking you know calculated
risk here and there
and gaining rewards she's the first
person to come and you know say oh
congratulations babe let's celebrate
together
but then i've actually kept the same
energy and
now it seems like she doesn't really
have the same energy so
who is the person that's falling off
okay so in other words i'm a hater
well because i still i still would um
celebrate your wins no
that's true but the only thing is let me
give you an example right uh so
literally i have access to a good number
of private members clubs
uh this is through the clients of mine i
train um high net worth individuals
you know celebrities you name it now
with these
okay there's so much contempt she has a
lot of contempt for him
like as he's talking about these high
with and then he has a bad habit of like
stonewalling her
when she brings up a concern like these
are these are terrible
attributes if you're talking and your
girl's rolling her eyes
and sighing in front of other people
[ __ ]
y'all got problems y'all got deep
problems membership clubs
obviously it's not everyone that's you
know invited
and i feel like that kind of affects
trauma whereas before
if we were going to like you know like a
normal type of
yeah average maybe not average joe but
you know the usual
then i'll kind of be oh babe you know
come along but when i'm actually you
know grafting
and chasing the bag as she said i don't
really feel like she needs to be present
and
she actually doesn't have an invite
anyway so okay that's not what we're i'm
not i'm not upset that i'm unable to
come to the events that you go to and to
the
gambling places because it's gambling if
you ask me it's casino isn't it
so the clubs you guys are going to and
the money you're spending some of it is
gambling all right
because everything he likes to say is
constructive clubbing is not
constructive it's not beneficial to
our relationship or to him even places
like that
he places too much emphasis on how they
look at him so you're out here doing
the most buying so many bottles pay in
10k for tables
and it doesn't make sense and i'm at
home being neglected when he comes home
he goes back to work
so my point is you're putting too much
emphasis on the way they see you
why is that you're trying to you're
supposed to be impressing me not them so
the type of people that i deal with
they're on another level to be fair
they're high net worth and
they work really hard for themselves now
for me to be able to kind of
be that act of service for them you can
imagine how hard i have to work
if they're calling you you need to
answer if they're sending you a message
whether it's a text or what's that
listen you need to be on point i'm able
to give them that service listen
sometimes you're gonna meet people who
are workaholics
if they were that way when you met them
and then y'all start dating and get
together and they still
are like that that's on you now if it's
a switch up that's a different concern
but this idea that you're going to date
someone and they're going to start to
pay more attention to you like
listen people who work 60 70 80 hours a
week they're gone
it affects the family it affects his
siblings it affects everyone negatively
because of their constant workout but
that's what they want to do
so you have to ask yourself yeah i want
to be with somebody who makes that much
money
but i don't like what it takes for that
person to make that much money
well that's one of the realities of that
line of work
people are gonna have to travel a lot in
some situations
people are gonna have to work long long
hours and when they come home
they're too tired to take you anywhere
right you guys have a higher quality of
life in some ways
but you might be neglected in that
process i'm not saying you should have
to accept that what i'm trying to say is
maybe this isn't the person for you if
you don't like how much they have to
invest
in what they want to be doing that's all
yeah but there's
there's there's balance there's balance
i understand which what you're saying
and you you're right you're absolutely
right like
right there like i said uh like i said
whenever when i do um conferences like
you know i got two phones i got
the iwatch i got you know the computer i
got the
i work right now i'm working at this
time
where i could be spending some time with
other people but when i spend time with
those people i turn all that [ __ ] off so
i'm not working so there's always a
balance that you have to
have when when you know you're working a
lot when you
don't have um you don't have a uh
conventional
nine to five where you clock into nine
you get off at
five and then everything after that is
all your time
you have to make free time for the
people that are not
part of that world that are not that i'm
all about
show business and all the things i do
but at some point
i gotta take care of the people that
that are not part of that business now
i've always been that way and working a
whole lot so there's not
there hasn't been a switch up that's
where i agree with you so if it's a
switch up it's a different thing
but even yours is more balanced you know
when you're talking about people who
work 80 90 hour weeks
that's not me and you you know i mean
like there are youtubers who work
way more than we do they work crazy
amounts and their families
take a hit i'm not saying it's a good
thing i'm not saying something you
should command i'm not saying they have
a good balance
i'm saying they don't want balance they
just want to be invested in their work
so if you come into that person's life
knowing what it's like for them
then that's on you at some point you do
what i'm saying don't be surprised if
if what you got is what you got here's
an
example if she's a career woman and you
want to turn her into a housewife
she's going to be a career woman and
that's fine that's okay to be a career
woman
but don't be mad if she's works all the
time that's her thing
exactly and she should be working all
the time if that's her thing
exactly you know what i mean if if a man
came to he was like she doesn't want to
be a housewife
was she did you guys have that
conversation before what did she say she
was going to do
what did y'all agree on probably a
conversation you had before but anyways
just for the record how would you like
him to change i don't know
i like i like his drive and that's kind
of why we're together
my point is there needs to be a balance
i'm happy for you to grind
see what i'm saying so a lot of people
like what success looks like they don't
like what it takes for
some people to get there right right the
idea of a of a high
value man six figure all this it sounds
good esoterically speaking
but in terms of having stability and
balance it's not practical for most
people
it's really not because the person could
be traveling all the time they could be
working extended hours
they could be environments that you're
not fond of their mental health can take
a whole they don't have time or energy
to take you out
to think that they can do both all the
time that's ridiculous and that's why i
realize a lot of people
like the finished product they don't
like the process but again we're in a
relationship
the problem with you you think we're
business partners we're not
i need love as well do you know what i
mean like i've got a business i work
but i still feed you i still love on you
but i don't get it's not reciprocated
i guarantee she doesn't make nearly as
much of something guaranteed so hang on
paul
do you feel that you're giving as good
as you get in the love
um stakes well to be fair i thought i
did
but now i kind of i'm thinking to myself
like does she
trust do you trust me we were rooting
for you though
you were this this is what i talk about
the stone wall when she brings something
up
either this man shuts down or diverts it
somewhere else like you you can't do
that you gotta
if i say hello you shouldn't say what's
in your bank account it should be like
we start a conversation right yeah let's
have some sequences this is really weird
well yes or no i do trust you okay if
you trust
me and you trust my judgment and you
know that
between the both of us we both got
ourselves to the position where we are
which is a better position than we were
in
why would you not continue to trust the
process
because you've eradicated the whole love
aspect of our relationship
i'm a woman i'm not wood do you
understand that i've got heart
now this is the problem that i have with
women right like for example with trauma
at night when we first started she knows
i'm hard working i was doing xyz what i
had to do okay
everything was fine she was happy i've
got a hard working guy okay hug kiss
okay cool nowadays when i'm coming back
late the same person's complaining
asking me where am i coming from and i'm
thinking what
fair enough i don't work overtime and
i'm doing other things on a different
level but i'm the same person so why
would you question it
can i just solve that what's the the
last
loving thing you did for denise denise
yeah denise
look we're not going to play the whole
turn each other against each other
when's the last time you bought flowers
forget about all of that let's get down
to what it is now just
just just to briefly go over this right
why did you bring this man to therapy
this is the worst platform to bring this
purse on um
as far as i understand you've been
called
or employed rather to basically help us
in our relationship to get better
right okay so how do you think
you're doing so far okay don't be rude
you know what he reminds me of of a girl
you used to know
my mom always thinks contractors are
trying to scam her i have never gotten
my mom a telephone provider internet
provider
plumber and she doesn't like read the
contract look at the billable hours he
was only here eight hours
why does it say ten i was like because
he traveled here an hour now you have to
cut
no no no no no he's stealing money from
us it's that same
african energy where it's just like
you're not gonna scam me that's what i'm
getting from here
the only difference is my mom would
smile at you and the moment you exit the
door she's like
go call his bus
your mom's a g my mom does not play
she's not getting played
uh i don't even know that woman i like
that woman i've seen that woman one time
that that woman
yeah yeah labor
which means it means thief in my
language
is what i mean what thief labor
yeah it's crazy because you're paying
for labour
okay i can answer that sherman don't
worry the fact is that i'm here to
enable you
to see through the fog that may be there
at the moment
i'm not here to give you an answer i'm
just helping you
discover what's going on
what's your success rate in terms of
like couples that have been to your
therapy sessions and have gone on to get
married
well i think you've already done your
research i did research
and i found out that a lot of people
gave you good reviews um a lot of them
have actually gone on to get married a
lot of them have resolved their
situation
um be open-minded i feel like people get
results from you if they're open-minded
didn't answer the question what's your
successory i need percentages i deal
with figures
what's this i'm afraid i don't work in
figures
does this man just snap at her rough
let's go you know what snappy snappy
i need some figures numbers yeah
percentages
yeah give me that yeah you're not there
i need to see it
paul is you dizzy blood
is you dizzy i work in people and when
people come back
it's because they're seeing results so
as far as i'm concerned
this is interesting to see a white lady
be so calm with a
with a black version of a karen when he
was asking for the numbers was basically
like
uh can i speak to your manager and she's
like uh listen excuse me sir
excuse me jamal i'm gonna need you to
just tone down the energy a little bit
the reason why things are like this uh
numbers numbers can i speak to your
manager
it's interesting the reverse of a white
lady being this calm things are working
so if we came back to your session that
means it's working
well you sign up for a certain number of
sessions see this man thinks it's a scam
you see what i'm talking about this man
so so if we sign up to a certain number
of sessions
you're going to make how much money if
we're both kind of
in line in terms of our goals and our
visions then i would
assume that we'd both basically be on
the same page is that wrong denise
no it's good when when couples are on
the same page
but are you on the same page
are you oscar i'm asking both of you do
you think
you're on the same page i feel as though
we
are on the same page of certain things
but again
as much as paul says i like to nag he
has a lot of issues with things that i
do
so paul just give me a little bit of
your background what business you in
yes
whoa
yo listen as much as i rag on her for
trying to bring you here when you didn't
want to come
if you were going to put forth this kind
of effort bro why did you come oh man
bruh wow that's funny that's funny well
stay home next time
yeah i'll answer the question babe so
what does my business have to do with
the religion just asking i just wondered
you know whether that was influencing
the way that you deal with life
sorry i'm a provider what is it that you
do i don't understand just what
i don't i don't see how this is going to
help our relationship in the long term
this is the problem that i have right
look with this denise lady i just feel
like
she's just asking lots of intrusive
questions that doesn't really relate to
the situation at hand
she's asking me what do i do like i make
money that's what i do like
it's a silly question what do you want
from me do you understand you're here
for a certain purpose
to help with the relationship do that do
you do anything together
any you know hobbies that you do
together aside from on our laptops in
the same room
maybe when we started dating we used to
like the same music
he was more fun now he's i don't i don't
even know who's sitting next to me to be
honest
and how do you feel i think that's bs
it's bs look music i'm a burner
boyfriend you
you you used to be but now i still
like that doesn't make sense if you like
something just stick to
you know
that's funny yo the art of
arguing about [ __ ] that don't matter
that's the art of arguing
but i write the i write the conversation
how are you gonna drop burner boy for
whiz kid that's crazy bro
i mean i rate them but not above burner
but she never said it was bro
[Music]
she said she still likes him but she
prefers whiz kid now
that was fun i think it's his way of
saying you're the one who's changed if
you don't know me it's like it's like yo
my girl likes some [ __ ] that i don't
like
and it's okay so that was the end of
episode one
let's be honest with that okay hey
listen i'm always gonna side with
brothers who look like they're from the
nation of islam you feel me like i gotta
show love
yeah you like them old tip [ __ ]
no temp hotep it just seems like for the
both of them they have
they have different views of what they
want from each other and they're not
practical about it
so that's what i get the expectations
they're really keeping expectations that
were not there in the beginning
trying to hold on to things that you
wish happened on the other person
listen you get with me and you wish for
someone that's gonna grow beard
it's not gonna happen okay that's not
what i want
that's not what i am that's not what i
will be
i can't that's why you have those
conversations you know you're dating
someone you're like yo would you be
willing to be a housewife
and if you lost your job would you mind
if i take a job and you have to be home
with the kids
you know like have those conversations
to find out where you guys stand
ask yourself do you even want kids
conversation is stupid they're not
they're really not and and especially
about stuff that's really important
you know like i consider whether or not
you want a career pretty important do
you want kids
very important if faith matters to
either party
have that conversation i'm not a
religious person if i was dating someone
who was
they would have to make some concessions
because i'm just not going to sit in
church
and start going to shia it's not just
something
it's not going to happen but you know if
you want to baptize the kids like i
don't care
dump him in holy water make him take a
bath in there i don't give a [ __ ]
but we have to have that conversation if
we don't then of course later down the
line you're going to be devastated
when you find out that i don't want to
go to church with you every sunday
because you were expecting that when we
got married that was going to happen but
we never talked about it right
so it's good to talk about these things
to find out where the other one side so
that later on you're not blindsided and
then you feel betrayed what betrayed you
wasn't your partner what betrayed you
was your own expectations
but you built expectations without
knowledge
and after that you resent the person for
the expectations that you had
but never spoke about and you really
just wished for
it's the same thing as just believing in
astrology you know what it's like bro
it's like when you buy a house but you
don't pay for an inspection
then you get plumbing problems later and
you're like
[ __ ] who told you to not have an
inspection done before you made a
purchase on a home
feel me so there's a certain level of
negligence that people have going into
these conversations they don't even
think about what's important
and you're seeing it now blow up in
their faces when
reality doesn't match expectations so
talk about it talk about it with the
people you date it's not corny
it's not it's not doesn't make you look
crazy or clingy and if someone thinks
that you are being that way
because you ask those questions probably
a good idea to
consider whether or not you want to date
that person seriously a relationship is
a huge investment
a marriage is an even bigger one what
person do you know that's going to
purchase a company
without doing a full-on research on the
company's history without asking a bunch
of questions
about what type of company it is does it
have any issues with tax problems
when i buy this am i taking on debt like
you should know all of that before you
purchase it it should be the same thing
that's why i tell people
this whole talk about love that's
secondary
that's the easier stuff the things that
people neglect
that lead to divorces or the stuff that
folks never talk about
they never talk about it and they just
expect for the best they
hope for the best yeah it's really not a
relationship is really not hoping for
the best
it's discussing a lot of things that's
why it's a lot of concession a lot of
discussion
a lot of things that are hard you know
having discussions but people don't are
not willing to have that
they're just willing they're just hoping
for the best and then they're dashing
out when things are not working
well so that's kind of what i gathered
from watching this but maybe you guys
felt differently when you watched it
what did you think about this couple on
this issue
if you guys liked today's video if you
guys want us to do a part two
be sure to like it alright like it right
now comment uh but yeah we'll be
covering
the other couple from the episode what
do you think yeah about everything
i said what i said you said you said i
[Music]
[Applause]
think
[Music]
ah
hold on